une situation sanitaire extrêmement
grave aux antilles les taux d'incidence
que n'a jamais connu en france retour au
confinement strict et évacuation de
patients nous sommes à l'été 2000 21 et
pourtant ces discours ne transportent
dangereusement au début de l'épidémie en
mars 2020 en outre mer principalement en
guadeloupe et en martinique
la quatrième vague de kobe 19 et d'une
violence jamais vue l asphyxie les
hôpitaux et reconfirme les populations
alors pourquoi l'épidémie s'est elle
bien plus rage aux antilles qu'en
métropole pourquoi cette brusque flambée
des cas dans des territoires
relativement épargné durant les
premières vagues on vous détaille les
raisons donc eu
[Musique]
ce chu est devenu un hôpital kobe dette
us est totalement transformé pas de
manière aussi importante qu'on l'avait
déjà fait dans les trois vagues
précédentes mais le drame actuel c'est
que cette organisation ne suffit pas du
tout par exemple cette nuit il y avait
une trentaine de personnes au service
d'urgence qu'il n'avait aucun lit pour
pouvoir être hospitalisés qui devait
l'être andré cabié et chef de service
d'infectiologie au chu de martinique et
comme bon nombre de ses collègues il
constate avec effroi le sévère rebond de
l'épidémie aux antilles inédit dans ces
territoires depuis le début de la crise
les taux d'incidence sont vertigineux
selon santé publique france le 11 août
il atteignait 1176 pour cent mille
habitants en martinique et 1855 en
guadeloupe ou encore 933 à saint
barthélemy et 518 à saint martin en
comparaison le sud de la métropole le
plus touché par l'épidémie affichent des
taux oscillant entre 600 et 700 nous
avons à peu près
6840 une semaine 1 qui pour nous est
énorme parce que au plus fort de la
deuxième vague gates est pour nous la
plus impactants nous avions 1904 par
semaine vous voyez c'est multiplié
quasiment par six comment expliquer
alors une telle différence entre la
métropole et les territoires d'outre-mer
tout d'abord comme souvent lors d'une
reprise des contaminations un
relâchement des gestes barrières à la
reprise la quatrième bague a commencé au
mois de juin avec au moment du décompte
final
il y a eu grand nombre de festivités de
rassemblement que ça correspondait aussi
à la fin de l'année scolaire un arrêt
quasi complet pour un certain nombre de
personnes de tous les gestes barré
variant qui était présent c'était le
variant alpha parieurs anglais qui se
transmet quand même facilement la
population effectivement on n'a pas bien
appréhendé la gravité de cette maladie
probablement parce qu'en première vague
n'ont pas eu un impact très important
sur la population ça eu à chaque fois un
impact important sur l'hôpital mais pas
sur la population la deuxième raison à
cette flambée des cas est sûrement la
principale il fallait faire la
démonstration que la vaccination est le
moyen le plus efficace de répondre à ce
variant delta malheureusement nos en dix
ans des livres si je puis dire une
démonstration cruel sont nos territoires
aux qui est problématique c'est qu'il ya
un taux de vaccination qui est faible
c'est moins de 20% de la population
totale qui a un schéma vaccinal complet
et donc du coup il ya de nombreuses
personnes infectées en outre-mer les
doses n'ont pourtant jamais manqué et
les centres de vaccination ont bien pu
ouvrir dès le début de la campagne de
vaccination
pourtant rien qu'en martinique et en
guadeloupe à peine 20 % de la population
est totalement vaccinés contre près de
55 % en métropole on a fait bien sûr
plusieurs sondages pour demander
pourquoi les personnes étaient
réticentes à peu près 60% d'entre elles
étaient plutôt d'un manque de recul on
veut voir un petit peu ce que ça donne
on a besoin d'avoir plus d'informations
et puis d'autres personnes qui elles
sont réticentes pour des raisons qui
sont un peu autres notamment d un petit
peu politiques ou des raisons peut-être
plus aussi dans le bas la culture ici
sur le territoire la vaccination pour
les autres est moins bien acceptées -
bellaing prise que ailleurs le troisième
facteur qui entre en compte c'est la
grande méfiance quand envers les
politiques que la science dans ces
territoires ultramarins les fausses
nouvelles sur la vaccination ou pour
minimiser la gravité de l'épidémie ont
beaucoup d'écho en martinique où de
nombreux habitants sans forme
exclusivement sur les réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs dans une tribune publiée le 2
août 35 scientifiques ultramarins ont
réagi ce retard dans la vaccination en
appelant leurs compatriotes à se faire
vacciner le plus rapidement possible une
défiance des martiniquais vis-à-vis de
l'autorité en général ce soit l'autorité
nationale ouvert le mental ce qui vient
de paris mais aussi l'autorité locale
vis-à-vis de la science aussi et
vis-à-vis de la médecine est un espèce
de militantisme et de positionnement
anti vaccins le poids de l'histoire
prend ici toute son importance car cette
méfiance à l'égard de l'état pour
notamment sa source dans le scandale du
chlordécone cet insecticide interdit en
france en 1990 a continué à être
autorisé dans les champs de bananes des
antilles il est accusé d'avoir
empoisonné les habitants de martinique
et de guadeloupe et provoqué une
pollution très importante et surtout
très durable donc la création d'une
méfiance derrière on peut le comprendre
un tout à fait maintenant si demain on
nous sur la crise de coville dont on est
dans une approche très transparent parce
que on sait combien c'est important
d'expliquer aux gens de leur donner les
chiffres de leur montrer ce qui se passe
vraiment et de leur dire ce que l'on met
en place et mais c'est vrai que ce fond
de méfiance existe enfin quatrième
explication c'est l'âge et le rôle des
comorbidités dans les formes graves de
la maladie comme en guadeloupe les plus
de 65 ans représentent 28% de la
population est vrai que la partie nick
est un département et dans les
territoires français les plus âgés et
dans lesquels il y à une fréquence très
très élevé que du diabète de
l'hypertension de l'obésité cette vague
là ce qu'on observe c'est qu'on a des
personnes de plus en plus jeunes c'est
des personnes de moins de 50 ans de
moins de 40 ans on a déploré ce week-end
une dizaine de décès tous les jours dont
des personnes d'une trentaine d'années
ces personnes là était tout soit en
surpoids soit obèses cette explosion est
donc bien multifactorielles si le
déconfinement le variant delta et le
retour au pays des antillais qui
travaillait en métropole a pu donner un
coup d'accélérateur à la circulation de
virus c'est bien la couverture vaccinale
qui pose problème sans celle-ci seul un
confinement strict semble capable de
soulager les hôpitaux et nos capacités
ne nous permettent pas de faire face à
cette épidémie mais je pense que pour
une région donnée aucun modèle
hospitalier ne pourrait être capable de
faire face à un tel afflux de personnes
globalement en france on l'a vu dans les
vagues précédentes on manque de médecins
réanimateurs d'infirmières spécialisées
de réanimation et ainsi de suite c'est
vraiment ça aujourd'hui il me bloque sur
l'ouverture de lits supplémentaires
[Musique]